on the morning of June 26 1997
corporal Wayne Martinez was working
alone in the shift command office a
restricted area for staff only
somehow three inmates got into the room
and overtook Martinez at his post I
think he was caught off guard when they
went in I don't think he was expecting
it at all
what happened next changed Wyoming State
Penitentiary forever
the inmates stabbed him repeatedly and
bludgeoned him with a fire extinguisher
Wayne Martinez was 27 carpel Martinez my
husband I know that there's no way he
would have just you know not fought back
and done anything when they were doing
this to him you know if he thought his
hardest the three inmates were quickly
captured two of them got life the other
is on death row
the Old North facility where the murder
took place now sits abandoned 100 yards
from the current prison it's a daily
reminder to every officer who enters WSP
that they can never let down their guard
just because inmates can be nice to you
and talk to you and stuff you know in a
second something goes wrong they get the
wrong kind of food they get you know
they don't get medication they don't get
a pill for a headache they can go off
and just turn on you you can never
believe that an inmate is your friend
any one of them can be dangerous at any
time if an inmate turns on an officer
there's only one weapon they have at
their disposal
pepper spray but in order to carry it
each new recruit must get sprayed with
it marker you're gonna go in there there
see three things written on pieces of
cardboard it's fish horse or pig
instructor assigns each recruit an
animal before they enter the shed horse
they have to find their animal and sign
their name under it the shed is full of
OC pepper spray OC oleoresin capsicum is
made from ground cayenne pepper it
forces the eyes shut and makes breathing
difficult and rare cases it's fatal new
recruit Travis De Palma is up next
after he signs his name he has to prove
he can fight through the pain long
enough to cuff someone it's not an easy
exercise but if he's ever in a
contaminated area on the job or worse if
an inmate should get a hold of his
pepper spray he must know he can still
maintain control
we've got your eyes open this place to
win thanks to him you're gonna make it
works with the water if you got your
eyes open look into the breeze open your
eyes open your eyes just like an
abortion
give you a couple of plates now it only
sucks for like a day or two they know go
away it is the worst experience ever
somebody is just crying tonight in your
eyes with sandpaper start to cut her oh
no I think this is just another tool on
our tool belt you know we have we have
all of our options available to us and
this is one of the last resorts you know
Oh see isn't something to be messed with
and it hurts